عامين وعلاقة معقدة للغاية
بين أردوغان وتركيا وحلف شمال الأطلسي
والولايات المتحدة لأنهم
أثبتوا أهميتهم في بعض النواحي
لصفقة الحبوب وما إلى ذلك ولكنهم أثبتوا أيضًا أنها
صعبة للغاية، فمن الصعب أن تكون
تركيا حليفًا صعبًا لأنه
مثلك  أشار إلى أنه من المهم جدًا أن أعني أن
الناتو لديه العديد من الدول ولكن تركيا هي
ثاني أكبر جيش وهناك
حق، لذا فهي على الأرض لذلك يمكن
نشرها بسهولة ولكن على مر السنين
كانت تركيا لديها أقل من واحد على وجه الخصوص
منذ حوالي 20 عامًا عندما كان
بالفعل  تركيا منفتحة وديمقراطية
والتي كانت ذات
عسكرة شديدة نعم، ثم مع
تحديات مختلفة مثل احتجاجات جيزي بارك
في عام 2013 ثم محاولة الانقلاب
ضده بعد بضع سنوات، قام باتخاذ إجراءات صارمة
وبدأ يصبح أكثر
استبدادية بكثير وهذا ما هو
جعله لا يمكن التنبؤ به بشكل لا يصدق عندما
يتعلق الأمر بكونه حليفًا قويًا للغرب
وبالطبع قبل أن تكون تركيا
نوعًا من الجسر الفعلي بين
الشرق والغرب، لكن في عهد أردوغان
أسقطوا محاولاتهم للانضمام إلى
الاتحاد الأوروبي لأن هناك الكثير  للكثير من
الشروط التي لا يرغبون في
الوفاء بها